played the clip I just sent you Rob it's
26 seconds the sanz's campaign manager
lost it what when he was being
interviewed on I want to say NBC or
whoever this is what channel is this
yeah NBC oh wow he was Furious to say
why are you guys calling it why are you
guys calling it so early why are you
guys calling it why are you guys calling
it and and partly they're right on why
you're calling it but they were calling
it because the lead was so yeah you know
massive that it's like listen guy what
do you every this guy yeah can you play
this clip
uh hope you enjoy I think I think it was
results from some sort of survey or
something not not even true votes well
no no no this was this was projected
Based on data and science data and
Science and not actual election results
and we'll have some of our experts
explain explain how that was decided and
why it was called in the way it was
later in the
show because I don't like it if the left
does it the right I don't care if
anybody does it just just wait the
numbers are going to go a little bit
higher you know you got a a little bit
more to go and then you can say and the
way you can do it based on math cuz the
last Iowa I think it was 180,000 people
that casted a vote this time it was a
can you P some numbers said 116 some
said 130 it wasn't a big number no so
you know why a lot of people didn't even
show up they're like listen this for
what Trump has got such a big lead what
am I voting for there's no reason to
show up and even in our last
presidential election which was so
contested the most of the news media you
know the big ones televis and on L ones
waited till the polls close and they
would say we're waiting till the poll
closes in Wyoming however Trump has a
very significant lead over Biden they
would say that but we're waiting to call
it and put the number on the board until
the polls close they've usually have had
that sort of I'm going to use a word
here gentlemanly approach to the
elections so I think that guy has a
point why don't we wait till the polls
close yeah well look to use some
football terms when the KC Chiefs were
up 24 to7 against the doll dophins with
4 minutes remaining in the game they're
like all right guys we're ready to call
it and then there's people be like hold
on there's still 4 minutes left the
Dolph believe me the Dolphins aren't
making a comeback the Santa ain't making
a comeback Trump if you're watching that
video if you're watching that video they
had only done Trump at 25,000 no I get
that so to me all I'm saying is wait
another hour like what do you wait
another hour so for example for us like
when we would do recognition if you did
it too early guys would and moan
about I'm like I don't even want to hear
you bitching a so guess what let's wait
till the results are done and here's
what guess you're lost okay cool let's
move on and then that was a kind of
that's the only thing I'm saying that I
support what the guy saying and uh you
know Tom kind of has an exp look at the
smile on Tom what are you laughing at
Tom I'm laughing what what what Adam
just said yeah because in the NFL unlike
Arizona elections Dolphin players don't
mysteriously and suddenly appear in the
end zone yeah so it's like seven more
for the dolphins where' that guy come
from yeah weird yeah definitely weird
sometimes the Dolphins make me what a
rough week to be a Dallas cowbo fan
right like the worst loss in the history
the Dakota cuz their quarterback's name
is Dakota and they suck Dakota by the
way Jack Prescott name is Dakota yeah
Stephen A Smith's loving it he he had a
great week with Jason Whitlock and now
cowbo but it's but it's pretty bad on
what happened so if you like this clip
and you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right
here